hello and welcome everybody to the
Macmillan Center I'm Ian Shapiro its
current director we're delighted to be
able to host Prince Moulay Hassan bin
Abdullah of Morocco as the speaker for
the coca-cola world fund lecture at Yale
this lecture was established in 1992 by
the late Roberto what was Etta who's the
former chair and CC of the coca-cola
company and an alumnus of yells class of
1953 the prince also known as Hisham
Alawi is the grandson of the late King
Mohammed the fifth father of the modern
independent nation of Morocco his
foundation the Hisham Alawis foundation
has created programs at Stanford at UC
Santa Barbara at Princeton and a chair
at the collège de France in Paris here
at Yale he is generously funded an
interdisciplinary research program on
our Arab governance and local
development the foundation also produced
a whisper to a roar an award-winning
documentary on the struggle for
democracy around the world writing on
the Arab world mullah Hisham has
published numerous essays in a wide
variety of venues his memoir which is
translated as Diary of a banished Prince
as was published in 2014 and has since
appeared in several languages including
Arabic and Spanish in the past he served
as a principal officer for community
affairs with the United Nations keep
peacekeeping mission in Kosovo in 2000
worked with the Carter Center said on
the MEA Advisory Committee for Human
Rights Watch and served as a consulting
professor at the center of democracy
development and the rule of law at
Stanford
hiss hiss ah Malawi is currently
affiliated with the Carnegie Endowment
for international peace the title he's
chosen for today's lecture is the Arab
Spring reloaded I'm delighted plea and
pleased to introduce Prince Moulay dish'
thank you thank you very much thank you
Professor Ian Shapiro for that kind
introduction I'd like to thank the
Macmillan Center for hosting me and
inviting me today the coca-cola lecture
fund world fund that Yale misses Rehema
part of macmillan center and the
assistant to mr. Shapiro professor
Shapiro who has coordinated this event
or hasn't initially invited me also
Marilyn whose help in coordinating has
been very important I'd like to thank
also mr. Larry Stanfield who drove me
into a beautiful New Haven well I should
moderate that into beautiful New Haven
at night I'd like to thank all of you
for being present I know this is an
extremely busy time in the semester you
all are approaching exams and your
workload is is is exerting quite a few
quite some duress on you but you have
still come I am particularly honored and
privileged to to acknowledge among us
my Dean or the Dean IVA Gossman that was
Dean when I was a freshman at the other
place further down south that was in
1980 oh my god 36 years ago that's a
long time just very very briefly
somebody asked me before coming into the
building about the foundation dation
Alawis foundation it's not a foundation
on that that is taking care of democracy
advocacy it's a really a Research
Foundation that tries to bring scholars
together and and faster in the process
understanding and debate on the region
on this I will not try to burden you a
lot I will try to limit my remarks to
3540 minutes so that we can have a
dialogue and a conversation afterwards I
will separate my talk into three
segments the first one will be about the
origins of the Arab Spring I will try to
be as succinct as I can on that because
I know even if some of you are not
political scientists or social
scientists you are very well immersed in
the media around us and you have a very
good idea of what are the causes of the
Arab Spring and the trajectory of the
Arab Spring and the fact that a lot of
the places have disappointed in terms of
results I will then transition into what
we have now and what I think or what I
have dubbed as retrenched
authoritarianism and then I will try to
explore the future but with a lot of
caution because social science is not
about prognostication but we can tell
from the present or from the trends that
we see what we can expect in the future
so as you know we can ask we can begin
with the question is the Arab world
better off today than five years ago
when it first started
is it worth asking this question because
many people and especially Arabs are now
doubting very
much that this is the case as you know
in 2011 the Arab Spring burst onto the
scene and the Middle Eastern scene like
a shock of adrenaline jolting the status
quo the regional wave of revolutionary
protests marked a collective and
contingent moment of hope of change
where activists and protesters were in
support of dignity and reform today it
is easy of course to shrug off the Arab
Spring as an anomaly and an ominous
interruption in what is otherwise a very
stable trajectory of stubborn
authoritarianism apart from the bright
case of Tunisia of course the states
that saw underwent an Arab Spring have
maintained their regime structures or
have relapsed into even more severe
authoritarianism or have simply
fragmented and plunged into civil war
as you know Libya and Yemen have
collapsed and their states and countries
are torn apart with competing groups
provincial warlords and foreign
interventions more than a decade after
the fall of Saddam Hussein Iraq remains
marred and basically stifled in
sectarian violence with structure on
security and very weak governance Egypt
as you know has returned to military
rule with a degree of authority
autocratic rule that has been seldomly
seen it's worse than under Mubarak and
it's even much worse than under
President Nasser Syria has become one of
the most desolate places on earth with
half of the population displaced either
internally or across the borders and
half of the cities destroyed with no end
in sight to the civil war much of the
countryside as you know has become
basically a better battleground for
regime loyalists and for elements that
have descended from all over the world
and in the middle of this of course Isis
stands with a carved out territorial
fate and ruling with such violence and
barbarity seldomly seen since the Middle
Ages so given all this evidence it is
little wonder that so many people and
Arabs are asking this question are we
better off five years into the Arab
Spring it's a legitimate question it's a
difficult question but I think above all
it is the wrong question to ask it is
wrong because it presumes and it assumes
that this could have been avoided that
is not the desolation of the violence
that the Arab Spring that the explosions
and operations could have been avoided
the Arab Spring was indeed an avoidable
due to a single underlying factor and
that plagues most of the countries in
the region and that is stagnant
autocratic rules closed autocracies that
have long governed the region have as we
know a meager capacity to meet needs of
the people they suffocate pluralism
demand obedience and see themselves as
above all reproach I think the worst
thing that they have done is it
basically destroyed the social fabric of
societies what we call in French Lillian
so she are the social link that spring
that exists in every society that at
succint moments in history will come up
to the surface and lead the people at a
nation through so if the question
demands an answer then yes we are worse
off five years into the Arab Spring
there's no question about that today I
saw an article in The Guardian written
by Ian Black who has conducted a survey
who has referred to a survey and the
statistics in that article or as follows
I'll just give you three statistics
which are very eloquent and expressive
72% of Arabs asked question in 2002
welcomed the Arab Spring as opposed to
36% in 2016 so the difference is
absolutely enormous in 2011 92%
said that living in a democracy is an
absolute must
so there you go these are statistics
basically tell say it as it is in a
material sense of the Arab world is much
worse off today because of the violence
and because of the impasse most of these
countries find themselves in we also
know or we also can say that it's going
to get worse these uprisings will
continue to RuPt until the fundamental
problems are addressed and the most
important of these problems if there is
the right to gain a voice in the
governance of these countries like a
body that must suffer a fever due to an
infection the Arab world will know a lot
of spasms a lot of contortions until it
can overcome this ailment one thing is
sure we cannot go back to the past a
time when governments ruled with
impunity expecting unflinching and
unconditional allegiance the Arab Spring
awoke something that will never be
erased and never be quelled the
underlying thirst for dignity and
freedom whether it expresses itself
peacefully or with violence so with that
very brief introduction I'll move to the
first component of this talk as I said
what are the origins of the Arab Spring
I touched upon them very briefly I will
evoke one or two more points before I go
to the next section
first the origins of this Arab Spring
tell us much about the underlying
political decay the Arab Spring was
characterized by a common feeling a
common sentiment that extended from
Morocco to Bahrain that collective
combination was I said was a combination
of rage anger and also the feeling that
they were led down by their governments
the autocratic state was not accountable
but worse I think what grieved Arabs
most is the fact that it was not
it that with all the mandate the black
mandate that it had many of the problems
that were that have begun with
independence basically stayed the same
and got worse this was a pan-arab
movement but one that did not invoke the
usual pan-arab issues like support for
Palestine or the anti Western anti
Zionist conspiracy around indeed the
Arab Spring was decoupled from these
traditional problems and people looked
inward to the problems in each country
and the slogans in the mobilization had
to do with what citizens of each
respected countries were undergoing
rather than the blame the problems for
foreign conspiracies of course
conspiracy theories still exist but
they're nothing like they were before
before everything was blamed basically
on America there's some of that too you
will hear left and right that the Arab
Spring was designed in Washington you
will hear that but of course it's not
doesn't hold water in fact I will tell
you a very brief very brief story about
this before coming here on Sunday I was
at my Barber's and he was giving me a
shave and he tells me I hear you're
shooting a commercial for coca-cola at
Yale
and I say what do you mean he said yes a
commercial the Arab Spring
what does coca-cola have to do with the
Arab Spring so I tell him you know
there's a there's a market segment it's
very important and he says really I said
yes and I tell him you know the next one
will be in Tahrir Square and he says
really and at that time III making sure
that there that the blade was on my
massage far away from the jugular
because this guy's it's not the Barber
of Seville he's he is a barber for four
generals officers and and many and I
said in you know there's even an
endorsement by Morsi and he's gonna he's
gonna say something you know from jail
and and he'll have his beard shaved off
and he said I knew it this is a
conspiracy
this is Arab Spring was all about this
so just to tell you there's this
unavoidably there's some of that but it
for most part people know what this is
about so you know political regimes
targeted by the Arab Spring protests
movements were a cohort of with a lot of
variation okay some were extremely
oppressive that maintained closed
systems silent critics and control
public spaces and basically went after
their opposition others were more open
more manipulative more strategic
employing divide and rule tactics
pitting some social groups against the
others and utilizing a facade of
parliamentary elections to co-opt people
and to continue to continue you know to
continue the the more the softer kind of
authoritarian rule over the past decade
most governments confronted growing
demands from below for greater
participation and voice and also for
economic demands people simply wanted to
to share the dividends of prosperity
more than their parents and it was
absolutely normal and in response the
line of the Arab states was to appease
easiest of middle classes and these
demanding populations basically with
promised some more jobs and development
so we basically knew an arrow or an
ideology of developmental ISM however we
know after the fact today that even as
late developers Arab states are no Asian
Tigers the Middle East did not replicate
South Korean industrialization or
Singapore and modernization or even
Taiwanese development they simply could
not connect to globalization and to use
globalization as a lever to no sustained
growth of 8% over five ten years over
ten years this is what makes you
basically take off it cannot
economically why it's one simple reason
they were saddled in paper-money of
politics and endemic corruption and
basically clientelism
and this is the result of specific
social factors in the arab world which
make it impossible to replicate the
asian experience it was not just
impossible no matter what we here and
tunisia is the quintessential example at
that Tunisia was the as close as one
could get as a Tudor to the Asian tiger
at eight tiger and we saw precisely what
happened there had been of course and we
must say this and we must stress this
because we cannot set for ourselves a
straw man we have to look at situations
objectively and analyze them there have
been of course centers of excellence
pockets of growth in select economic
sectors certain countries have known
thriving banking and finance sectors
information technology has boomed in
Jordan no question about it
textile manufacturing in Egypt in my own
country a lot of the aerospace and a lot
of the IR knotek's components and the
wiring are in fact done in Morocco
Bombardier Boeing all this industry is
transferring in Morocco so that's that's
undeniable but these will remain silos
of excellence they will remind very
limited I doubt that without fundamental
reform that
these will constitute will have enough
inertia enough critical mass to lead to
a economic takeoff and aggregate numbers
were very impressive into 2000's growth
was about five or even six percent but
it never trickled down the middle class
that was had difficulty maintaining
itself in some middle classes some some
moments even saw their opportunities
stagnate and their disposable incomes as
economists would say shrink in this way
the Arab Spring shattered the myth of
developmental ISM if if the Arab Spring
did something it destroyed two things I
think the concept of jammu kiya which is
hereditary succession in Republic and it
destroyed the Smith of developmental ISM
youth unemployment stands at thirty
percent the highest of any region and
simply preventing this figure from
growing just keeping it at that level
will require some 18 million new jobs in
the region constant promises of reform
never creating meaningful change and
citizens were told continually to wait
to wait for decades until the explosion
happens this under course the
fundamental motive that the Arab Spring
protesters had in common namely the call
for dignity and here I must say that
even five years after the beginning of
the Arab Spring with the burning
self-immolation
of Mustapha of was easy I am still
grappling with this concept of dignity
the fact that Arabs like any others are
so attached to dignity and justice which
is something very prevalent in any
culture in any religion is something
that doesn't surprise me but on the
other hand to ascribe rebellions to an
amorphous and vague feeling that we
cannot truly measure that remains
sometimes arbitrary and subjective
threatens to plunge us back to the
oriental tropes that decreed that there
was something about Arabs
that made them attracted and basically
really attached to authoritarian rule if
you remember five years ago everybody
treating the Arab Spring almost a lot of
people treating the Arab Spring Jesus
very obscene there is something about
the Arab psyche about their history that
they are attracted to authoritarianism
it was about the or authoritarian
exception in the Arab world you could
read this not not only in a local
newspaper in any of these countries from
Morocco to bar right you could in fact
you read this element and in foreign
affairs well that has been shattered by
the Arab Spring so still in each respect
the origins of these Arabs Arab Spring
tell us that to beware of orientalist
culturist assumptions about any region
culture is very important it is
extremely important in this eg but it is
a one factor among many others we cannot
simply reify it into the governing
paradigm it was like 20 years ago we
were talking about Confucian values
there was something in Asia that gave
the preeminent value to to hierarchy and
to and to submission to elders that's
something that this was something that
prevented people from feeling having
universal values so the same way we were
wrong there we were blatantly wrong or
some people were blatantly wrong about
the Middle East I have been saying this
for 30 years 25 I'm not going to make
myself more older so this comes into our
second to my second section so the Arab
Spring has ended or has paused it
depends how you see this I look at this
as the Arab Spring as something that's
still continuing and that will know its
ups and downs in fact it's not a
seasonal thing it's a it's a it has to
do more of a long-term cycle thing and
so I was saying to myself how are we
going to call this what we what we know
now I'm going to call this new
authoritarianism but if I
call this new authoritarianism it means
that we're back to the oriental tropes
so I'm going to call this retrenched
authoritarianism after all russia is
today is a retrenched authoritarian
regime what we see with Putin has
nothing to do with tourism it has
nothing to do with the recycled
political culture of Czarist Russia it
has to do with politics it has to do
with the tooling and strategic actions
of elites that are governing Medvedev
was became Prime Minister and then he
became president
what did Putin do Putin just created the
right laws to circumvent everything and
he made Medvedev into a constitutional
monarch this is an egg again a wonderful
eloquent proof that there's nothing
cultural about this culture plays but
there are limits so what is this
retrenched authoritarian let's give some
features let's let's let's describe it a
little bit indeed
Arab regimes have gone back into their
toolbox and they have retooled their
regimes and we have this kind of
authoritarianism which can loosely be
defined not simply as a return to the
status quo but rather the creation of
more intransigence and potent means of
controlling society the core strategy
behind retrenched authoritarianism is
crafting alliances with those sectors of
Arab societies that grew fatigue from
the social unrest and from the disorder
of the Arab Spring
so these segments the first segments
includes secular middle classes that see
Islamist movements as a threat a threat
to their way of life and a threat to the
secular identities that is an important
sector with which the new authoritarian
state is entered into an alliance the
second group I would say are lower
income workers who've seen unrest and
political chaos as detrimental to their
own sectors there are construction
textiles and of course tourism retail
and many other sectors and finally the
third leg in this coalition consists of
business elites and crony capitalists
who wish to restore some degree of legal
order in order that they wreak and
reconstitute their monopolies never the
first circle the first circle gets
burned and a revolution it's too too
much of a red flag they have to go
within with the leader but behind that
like in a Cell the second circle has to
take over and takes and reconstitute
itself and in the beginning they all say
we are victim of this you know of the
authoritarian regime excetera we're all
going to play by the rules but then
sooner or later when business becomes
the same day of course try to perpetuate
the same the same patterns as in the
past so in some there are three of these
sectors and at the heart of this sec of
this of this constellation of Alliance
is the state and keeps them together
they have they are divergent in their
origins but they're they're conjectural
interests converge at that specific
moment and of course this lies upon the
retrenched authoritarians also rests
upon the lethargy and the passivity of
the revolutionary generation whose
demobilization has opened space for
regimes to temporarily restore
themselves now beyond the strategy of
building alliances with these three
sectors I would say again it's only my
opinion there may be others it may be
less there are four tactics the state
will use four tactics to keep these
players aligned in this alliance the
four tactic the first tactic of course
is greater repression which can take
various forms but usually the guest has
a common purpose to neutralize any
autonomous organizations to monitor
public spaces and to reduce potential
for future insurrection and this
variation is across you know the kind of
regime type where the Republic's or
monarchies
in Egypt for instance the violent
suppression of all opposition including
not only the Muslim Brotherhood but
independent civil society student groups
NGOs is worse than what it was with with
NASA with NASA and it's worse of course
at what it was with with Mubarak and
just a simple statistic in 2014 there
are close to 1000 death 1000 death
whether in detention or or actually in
detention that statistic is in detention
forget the big events like am a sparrow
and other problems that happened after
the soccer game I forget where it was
you have 1,000 cases of arbitrary
detention and you only of course they
come up to the surface this happens
every day they come up to the surface
one a Western citizen gets killed like
the case of the Italian student it's
also different in that you're seeing a
return to the to the cult of personality
that is very powerful sees his cult of a
personality or or or how it is managed
is is basically much much more enhanced
than when under Mubarak he is called on
TV a prophet Savior it's not not only in
the same anymore we're not only the
president for lifetime we're in another
category in many countries as well
judiciary's have tightened you know the
space by resorting to anti-terror laws
which used which they use to criminalize
online speech and reduce maneuvering
spaces where Egypt embodies acute
repressions on the other side of the
spectrum there are more battle forms of
coercion and state control I think it
was Mandela that said that freedom
cannot be in half you either have total
freedom or partial freedom
yes philosophically but for social
sciences you still have to address the
issue of the variation of the spaces
that and the toleration of dissidents by
a regime and so in that sense you can't
have have have half a democracy you ever
have a democracy we don't but you can
have countries that that are partially
free in my country for example the
security forces went after the February
20 protest movements punishing many of
the dissidents of the original protests
with fabricated dubious charges the
government has constrained media Liberty
it has restricted the activity of the
IMD ash which is Association bowel
candid lung freedom now which is a new
Association that has been set up to help
journalists and also more classical
actors like adolescent which is an
outlawed basically an outlawed Islamist
movement it also imposes a lot of
pressure on individual and groups with
sustained smear campaigns I mean we're
talking about demonization character
assassination fabrication the classical
things I'm I'm sorry but coca-cola can
be banned in my country after this so I
hope you don't mind I'm I'm just going
to say that I've been tortured into
saying this there's a I've been
subjected to a ferocious bull dog called
Dan who's forced me to say things
anyways just to say that you know you
could visit some of these sites I can
give you the address after this talk and
you will see things that will really
make you either laugh or cry it depends
if you're Moroccan you can cry if you
use to this you're going to laugh like I
do so while the the ring is inherently
focused on threat of terrorism so forth
most of these states are trying to
dismantle what they see at the
infrastructure of dissidents
it's like an engineer basically we're
trying to get rid as much as the
structures the foundations so that when
the next time around comes around
basically these groups will have minimal
capacity to remobilize and the the
second tactic is a bit linked to this
basically it is setting up a dichotomous
discourse it's either us or breakdown
and civil war you choose and this the in
this way the choice given to citizens is
quite austere for it is acceptance of
stability enforced by repression or else
plunge into the darkness of Isis and the
breakdown that's a choice given and
there's a lot of there's a lot of war
mongering you know we found a cell here
we found a - flag there there and they
were imminently going to pass through
the attack so it isn't no way you can
always verify this but it is a it is a
tactic used to serve the stratagem I
developed before the third tactic is
more subtle and it's very interesting
and it really warrants a lot of research
it is the careful redeployment of
religion along puritanical principles
partly to sideline Islamists and partly
to assure the conservative branch or the
Conservatives sector and society that
their interests are held in mind in
Egypt for instance you've seen how
citizens publicly ate and drank during
Ramadan were basically arrested for not
showing respect to the Muslim faith we
are also we're aware of the shameful
subjecting a woman to virginity test by
the military and these tests have the
objective of humiliating and shaming
women while the security forces justify
this on the grounds of ensuring the
moral integrity of the army of the state
and have the woman themselves in Jordan
one of the Lord
new economic development projects in MN
is the boulevard jean is one of the
pointedly does not sell alcohol the
government has also strongly supported
the spread of Islamic banking and
supplement and implemented Islamic
financial principles within state
institutions such as the postal saving
fund well some economists will tell you
yes o we discovered this is a niche it's
important a lot of the money is not in
the economic sector so we have to
authorize Islamic banking oh and there's
it's one thing to authorize it it's one
thing when the state supports it and
basically advertises it and makes it a
priority that is clearly another
political game in Morocco last year the
state preemptively banned the
controversial film much-loved
which explored the problem of
prostitution through the eyes of for
women for prostitutes in the city of
Marrakech and the movie's objective was
to show the real phenomena of
prostitution to show the exploitation
and the vulnerability of women that find
themselves trapped in this predicament
this movie was censored and such
censorship was justified on the grounds
of upholding the moral order however
such an action also completely
circumvented the existing rules they are
rules that basically codify the
procedures and who would be involved in
those procedures to rate or to attribute
to ratings to movies and to even censor
to even censor material in any outlet
these expressions of religious identity
or selective so was not to dis effect
the secular middle classes and do not
intend to empower Islamists and other
religious groups rather this new mode of
operation deprives Islamists of
monopolizing religious discourse without
strengthening the discourse itself this
is very important this is intended to
weaken
fundamentalists or Islamist groups so in
that vein they recourse to more order
and to this to this discourse is at the
discretion of the state therefore it
cannot be predicted there are no rules
about what constitutes something that
touches the more order and the probity
and the Islamic faith they are something
that is something that is arbitrarily
decided upon and it's on a case-by-case
situation it's an ad hoc that's
precisely the point so that the state
has the only prerogative to do that it's
important to disaggregate a lot of
issues here there's also the question of
secularization there's also the question
of the place and the autonomy between
religion and politics but as that is
something which is a real problem that
is something that needs to be
deliberated democratically among all
Muslims it is not just the prerogative
in a democratic state just a prerogative
of a regime so that there are two issues
there and it's important to disent to
disentangle them we have no problem I
personally believe that you know if you
if you there we had a case two days ago
in Morocco of a case of homosexuals that
have been beaten by mobs and that have
gone to jail and they have gone to jail
for alleged acts that they have done in
the private sphere now what does the
private sphere have to do with the
public sphere
they have been finally released because
the judge made the distinction precisely
that is one thing which is absolutely
unacceptable i me as an individual I can
accept that people are free to have
their own sexual orientation but if
others feel that there is a problem but
to in the public sphere the autonomy of
religion and the autonomy and the and
the autonomy of religion and the
autonomy of politics that is something
that has to be debated by a society
democratically in a parliament with
voting mechanisms it cannot be the unit
unilateral a prerogative of the state
that decides that for the retention of
popular sovereignty it took two hundred
three hundred years in the West to
resolve this story but it's been
resolved and is still not resolved but
it's been addressed through mechanisms
of vote transparency and the protection
of rights of people that is a condition
that it's a scenic one on here so you
will hear more about this in the future
and this is a very this is a next
frontier where we will have a lot of the
politics unfold around finally I'd like
to say that the last tactic of
retrenched authoritarianism is increased
for interventions which are justified in
the name of fighting either terrorism or
fighting regional threats like Iran
indeed the use of the sectarian identity
the sunni-shia divide has been a major
factor in shaping foreign policies of
Arab regimes on the other side of the
Shiite divide of course Iran is using
the same tactics and while the Sunni
camp points the finger at the Hootie's
and that Hezbollah and the Syrian state
the Shiites of course point the finger
at Isis saying that it's a fabrication
of of the Sunni camp and more
specifically Saudi Arabia however
justified and however rationalized
geopolitically for interventions are in
the beginning they quickly evolved into
a way of drawing attention away from
domestic problems in Yemen we see many
Arab countries are now immersed in an
ongoing intervention that has resulted
in numerous civilian casualties with
limited military success same thing is
happening in Libya and the
course Assyria both civil wars have been
greatly amplified and escalated by the
financial contribution and military
contribution of Arab states in all of
its expressions in all of its tactics
retrenched authoritarians makes a very
risky gamble which I think will
eventually be untenable namely that
youth and social groups that are
demanding change can be permanently
deactivated in general I would say this
if I want you to walk away with the
conclusion general here is this
repression if you're on the one side of
the spectrum like Egypt social control
if you're on the other spectrum if it's
Jordan or Morocco is the manifestation
it's a symbiotic link I would say it is
the manifestation not of the power of
regimes or not only of the relative
power at a specific conjunction but it's
also the fear these regimes have of an
imminent threat of the resurrection of
these movements and basically you know
putting back the control or the fear
back into putting the genie back into
the box
I will now finish and if you'll allow me
five more minutes I will finish with
what can we expect or what are we to
expect what is plausible what lies ahead
as I said it's very hard to
prognosticate it is very hard for me to
predict the timing or the sequence of
another explosion of another
insurrection of the revitalization of
the Arab Spring but my sense is that
it's pretty much inevitable given this
resurgence of this kind of aggressive
authoritarianism and the the demand for
voice which is there and the
continuation of the same structural
problems in fact the worsening of these
problems a little perspective is
necessary here if you ask somebody in
2010 to imagine a Middle East in which
there would be
Egyptian revolution there would be a
counter that the Muslim Brotherhood
would have a president there would be a
counter-coup and in Syria
you would have basically the crumbling
of the air above the Assad regime an
intervention of Russia like in
Afghanistan alongside the Hezbollah you
would have the emergence of a new jihadi
group which is carved itself basically a
territorial state and which makes a
al-qaeda look like a more reasonable
alternative a yemeni civil war with a
coalition of Arab states and finally
finally and worse importantly a Tunisia
featuring a democratic regime in which
Islamists and secularists live together
Islamist and secondaries living together
and building common institutions had you
said said that to any arable any person
in 2000 said 10 there would have thought
that you were insane insane for any of
single one of these elements to happen
let alone all of them together which
means in a sense that we are on an
unchartered territory here expect the
unexpected
when resurgence of authoritarianism
meets the undeniable desire for dignity
again when those two curves again meet
there will be a reawakening there will
be a reigniting of the spark the next
revolutionary wave will be more intense
it will be more violent why because
people understand today that there is no
time talk about reform this is not about
a debate about reformism about promises
it is a debate it is about transferring
it is about transitioning into real
consensus and pluralism it is about also
satisfying the enormous economic
problems as I said which is which is
getting worse above all I think there
are many lessons to be learned in this I
think we can learn that one there is an
example that Tunisia as I said as a
Tunisian democracy has taken root and
that is possible it will sooner or later
we hope take root and and thrive and
that will be a powerful example the
rebellion lies not only in the
organizational networks but as I said it
lies in the minds of people
something has you know something is born
something is different today it will
never be the same again
the strategic occupation of public
spaces the use of social networking
technologies a mass outreach effort will
eventually outpace regime efforts to
control them and a certain moment always
this is always the regime can be one
step ahead than the opposition can take
the lead but sooner or later these have
a tendency to all you know as as things
get charged I have convergent and tip
the balance and above all I think this
is the most important lesson of all
protest movements have learned the most
critical lesson namely that overcoming a
regime is not the final step it is just
the beginning
militants cannot rely on others like the
youth in Egypt the youth in Yemen the
youth in Jordan the youth and Morocco
cannot rely upon others to act for them
but instead need to organize into new
political forces and translate their
energies into entering politics this is
the one thing that distinguished this
region from let's say either Latin
America where the student unions were
more active or even Tunisia the ugt day
and many civil society organization went
directly in politics they were not
simply overseeing the process and
applying pressures on the actors so as
militants grow mature they will
transform from
the Pepsi generation - the coke
generation Pepsi is invigorating it's
refreshing
just like coke but Coca Cola's got
gravitas there's something there's
something different about it and it's a
whole difference in politics it's not
about just screaming in the street it's
cotton Adamo Islamism we want the regime
out or we want to reform the net out
they've reformed the regime it's about
entering into a room and talking to
generals and saying general what are we
going to do next the next step I will
not put you on trial I will not do this
I will do that what are you willing to
do for me so that we can packed away
find a way out of this of this conundrum
and make it a plus plus game not a
zero-sum game and that's very important
I am I am I want to stress something I'm
not a revolutionary but I believe in
people's sovereignty and I believe at
moments there will be imposition from
below once there is some position below
one has to support it but the better way
out of a crisis is a negotiated
settlement something that will avoid the
Weiden of violence and someone that will
give incentives to everybody and make
everyone a stakeholder in the process of
political transformation and I think
it's a fundamental distinction and I
think students of history see you know
as can't glorify revolutions it was a
must once it happens then you have to
make the best out of it but if it can be
avoid then I think it should be avoid
and I think you've seen you know the
French Revolution the Iranian
revolutions this is what happens you
have populist ideologies that come in
place and you have vindication and you
have blood and then you have a
generation lost and then you have the
military coming and saying look we have
to keep peace and order
so trying to avoid that but not avoiding
it two ways
more time but avoiding it to advance in
a steadfast way by a political pact by
contractual arrangements I think it is
the way out in this region specifically
that we have a polarization between two
groups Islamists and secularists who
that polarization is not going to go
away it's going to stay and we also have
armed forces there are not just
institutions that are not just
institutions that are defending the
integrity or the independence of a
nation they are stakeholders since the
beginning since the inception of the
nation the Egyptian army is a
stakeholder it's a very fabric is a very
comprising component of the Egyptian
state the same for the Algerian for the
Algerian Armed Forces so if we can look
ahead the Arab Gulf the mushroom and the
Maghreb will each experience more unrest
but shaded through their own unique
experiences and unique structural
factors most Gulf countries suffer from
weak and fragmented civil societies and
lack of established political party
organizations sooner or later oil prices
will come up and then you will have the
rentier state and then you will have
demobilization it's very it's
predictable civil societies and social
actors in the mushrik or different they
are more organized vocal in these
countries which implies a far greater
level of mobilization and uprising state
boundaries will not fundamentally change
I think but the nature of the political
substance within this within this
geographic spaces I think will change
for instance defeating Isis inherently
means addressing the grievances of the
Sunni population that have been
brutalized they have been basically cast
out marginalized economically from from
from the dividends of oil and petroleum
so addressing Isis defeating Isis not
only bombing them and drying them up
financially it also means addressing the
grievances
of the Sunni population Egypt in the
mash recalled faith will ultimately face
another uprising as the state fails to
resuscitate the the myth of
developmental ISM it is very hard for
economic overhaul of the Egyptian
economy when the regime basically
requires or insists on such centralized
control over society I finish with the
Maghreb where I think is the most
hopeful region in most hopeful region
for prospects of genuine pluralism I
will I am at 40 minutes I will give me
two more minutes bear bear with me
please in Algeria so the the major
pillars propping up the regime of course
our oil rents and the militaristic
networks of the state apparatus however
society remains very active very
mobilized and also abides by the
implicit pact of non-violence between
the population in the state which is the
legacy of the civil war any future
democratization would require social
forces to overcome the entrenched regime
financed by oil and protected by the
deeply embedded military in Morocco we
have reached a reasonable consensus
about the state of politics
five years after promulgating the
Constitution the underlying structure
power has not fundamentally changed
despite the formation of a new
parliamentary majority with the
Islamists leading it all major domestic
foreign policy decisions still go
through the monarchy in my book in my
book
Jean La Paz Bonnie diary of a banished
Prince
I should call it general of a former
Prince as one student on the internet
she wrote very intelligently and I like
that title before my next book
I argued that the picture more Niall
nature of the monarchy itself is a true
Rizal debt of Moroccan authoritarianism
I will add another dimension to that to
the institutional architecture of
politics alongside with the use of
religion to legitimize the monarchy are
all carefully tuned to maintain the
state of affairs but since then I have
refined my thinking and added a new
dimension with I think I will submit to
you and I say this the current direction
of the Moroccan state is marked by
departure from past orientation until
the mid 1990s mark monarchy perpetuated
the double discourse and it was a
cynical double discourse was smart
astute 2-digit but it was cynical it
constantly strived to contain popular
sovereignty by instrumentalizing the
discourse of traditionalism within the
Moroccan City but it was firmly lodged
within this paradigm by contrast the
present regime reigns through a formula
of what I would call political dualism
in which that tradition ISM is pursued
but alongside other ideas it espouses
the language of modernity and democracy
and has even sponsored progressive laws
and these are realities these are not
just stratagems these are realities and
we have to org we have to recognize them
the the rule for example the law
lowering the voting age to 18 and
improving gender equality these are real
accomplishments and they go in the
direction of democracy however at the
same time the present regime is very
identity requires a hegemonic
traditionalism that hearkens it back to
the pre-modern area I think the
culmination of this dualism is the
constitutional reforms of 2011 which
have announced the death of the magazine
which is a traditional monarchy as we
call it in Morocco by proclaiming the
birth of a new era proclaimed it but the
death certificate was never signed
these institutions are in parallel this
is an unsustainable dualism in my in my
view and that allows each side to
perpetuate itself and constrain and
gives the impression of a governance
running on autopilot it's like an
honorary who loyally and effectively
administers the asset of a state long
after its owner's passing the Maracana
regime is running the machinery of a
patrimony estate but I'm not actually
deciding anything that is fundamental
about the system itself in the future
this dualism has empowered a very narrow
set of political actors within the state
with the effect of making the monarchy
first among equals with other centers of
power such as economic coalition's
and security forces within this ecology
you have the regime that strives to
maintain itself alongside or in a better
position alongside other actors but this
is a horizontal arrangement but there's
nothing vertical it's short of
empowering or short of truly installing
popular sovereignty this dualism
perversely shapes and conditions the the
strategies of parties themselves the PJD
today sees itself basically as an actor
that seeks not only to promote the
Islamization of society but also to
entertain the illusion that by entering
political institutions from within like
a Trojan horse
it can happen somehow rally the monarchy
to its side and divorce it from other
state institutions I think that is an
illusion and the difficulty precisely
lays here while until the 1990s
political opposition mobilized around
the goal of dislodging the magazine
today new opposition forces congregate
around a much broader and much more
elusive and difficult goal and that is
overturning this duel
this difficulty precisely resides here
because the goal of overturning this
dualism is extremely hard to discern
requires pedagogy to efficiently
mobilize more people so the implication
here is I'll put it in political science
terms so maybe if you're any social
scientists here that will understand me
and even from other disciplines it's the
old paradigm of ik liberalism the more
you advance in liberalism the more
there's political liberalization the
more chances you have at one point it
will be unsustainable for everything and
then we transition into democratization
if what I'm saying is true if my hunch
here is true then that liberalization
will reach an asymptote it will never
cross a threshold of democracy because
there's something structurally inbuilt
that will make this system stay like
this be a hybrid and at best a
competitive authoritarian regime meaning
that elections and and and institutions
will be used as a facade to capture
political actors but never go behind and
the implication for for political actors
is precisely that well how do we do to
go beyond that you know what do we do if
we if we're in the street and requiring
change and Islamism and then we come out
you know somebody Trump's us with this
constitution what do we do we that's
precisely the point the point is we have
to understand that if this dualism
exists that it is elusive and that
requires a kind of mobilization that
read that that needs different type of
politics and the same thing for
political actors once they're trapped
into this now of course there will be
always politicians that will like this
game because it's the gravy train but
not all of them are like that not unlike
the privileges a matter a lot of them
wants genuine serious change for their
country and if they go into politics is
not just to convey legitimacy on the
regime but it's also because they
believe that institutional work is
important and that battles are waged not
only outside of politics but within
politics not only in civil society
is an institution so this is something
to think about if the game is set up by
a structural constraint which we do not
see or which we do not identify properly
because we have not thought about it
identity then we risk we may we run the
risk of turning in circles anyways but
as far as this my sense this dualism is
a galen contradiction which will
eventually collapse upon itself thus in
the medium term in the short term it can
work but in the long term I think the
monarchy is vulnerable to social and
political contestation from below
especially as actors like the PJD lose
their appeal and their political
attractiveness vanishes over time for me
the resolution of this dilemma of this
dualism is to shift out of this dualism
altogether and occupy the pole directly
opposite to the old pole of
traditionalism and that pole is the
perspective of popular sovereignty thank
you very much
you